Coffee on a plot wait who are you I'm
with you later
I know you are what are you doing in my
video you're ready No
yes my video this is clearly a face
behind me videos every week and you're
infringing upon it if you don't remove
yourself I will be forced on YouTube
security don't go get that won't they
have me on hold
me too I don't fear is a phenomenon you
might be familiar with to demonstrate
I'm going to enlist the help of Craig
benzine otherwise known as
here's Greg sitting at his desk editing
one of his videos it's late he's getting
tired anything's another cup of coffee
is in order so he he goes into the
kitchen pours himself a cup and realizes
that he has to go into the time machine
room cuz he needs to get the 22 second
what did he need he can't seem to
remember the first impulse is to go back
to the kitchen stand by the coffee
machine and oh oh yes yes yes now he
remembers he needed the poem I'm sure
you've all had this experience before
the experience of arriving somewhere
only to realize that you've forgotten
what you went there to do why does this
happen well last year neurological
researchers from no today published an
article called why walking through
doorways causes forget it's a it's a
good title and their thesis is that at
all times our brains are operating
within something called an event model a
collection of memories relevant to the
current activity walking through a
doorway can unintentionally purge this
model because whatever was happening in
the old room is less likely to be
relevant
now that you've changed venues why do
our brains do this to us
well because normally event models
operate beautifully it would be
impossible to keep all of our memories
at the fore of our mind so our brains
employ this incredible mechanism to keep
all the relevant memories within reach
an event model is being built in your
brain right now oh yes but I'd like to
make a larger point here if I met you
may Thanks
see this whole business with event
models gives us a great universally
recognizable example of the fact that
our brains are busy every moment with
activities of which were not aware in
fact before we are aware of any one
thing that we do there are a series of
neurological activities preceding it
Benjamin Libet a pioneering scientists
in the field of human consciousness
famously proved that activity in the
brain can be measured some 300
milliseconds before the person feels
that he has decided to move today with
the use of MRI that estimate has been
extended to something like 6 seconds how
should this be extrapolated in regard to
a concept we all know as free will free
wills at the basis of nearly all our
belief systems it founds not only moral
considerations but legal ones the
concepts of incarceration and
retribution are bound up with
responsibility which is bound up with
free choice but as we've seen our
choices proceed from neural activity of
which we are again
aware so does does this mean for example
that a murderer complete the defense my
brain made me do it
Einstein didn't believe in free will yet
he still believed that murderer should
be put in jail why well because they're
dangerous the fact that neural activity
proceeds and determines our choices
doesn't mean that the murderer can
separate the part of himself which is
responsible for the act of murder we are
choosing all the time
we can't help even with the knowledge
that we can choose what we choose we
can't stop choosing you can sit there
and do nothing but doing nothing is
itself a choice and one that gets harder
with every second eventually you'll
decide that this business of doing
nothing is a waste of your time and
you'll choose to get up so maybe we
should imagine our consciousness is
something like a river choice exists as
a part of that river but some ways
downstream from the source and farther
downstream from the choice is the action
and the action has real consequences in
the world around you and those
consequences to the extent that you're
around a witness them have an effect on
the river as a whole see that the
mysterious source of the river for the
most part is not acting against you it's
not an external consciousness and it's
not a random decision generator it acts
in harmony with your beliefs and ideals
with what makes you happy and sad and
it's informed by the consequences of
your choices and by the choices of those
around you and by the environment in
which you live and grow there is an
experiential disconnect here which is
hard to overcome when you look back over
your day your month your life you feel
as if you were the author of your
choices you feel as if you chose this
road as opposed to that road that over
time this free decide or what you call
AI has built its own identity the
problem is that this is impossible to
reconcile with the fact that at every
moment of your life you're being
informed by unconscious processes like
say event models free will is an
illusion it's difficult to accept it's
difficult for me to accept that my
consciousness is telling me a story
about myself which isn't true but I can
know it despite my feelings and I can
remind myself of it when I take myself
too seriously or I'm too hard on myself
for mistakes and maybe in endeavoring to
understand this part of me I can be
I'm more empathetic toward those who
like me like all of us try so
desperately hard to control their lives
and trip up in the most spectacular ways
yes Dee I remember what I was supposed
to do what I have to save the world from
this nuclear explosion by setting the
time machine
I don't wanna win around us to me over
what it mean so will it be to do it